my first paper that was out in 1991
um
the the big puzzle then was
um where's all this japanese money
coming from because in the 1980s
japanese money had been flooding the
world buying up
everything in in in the us uh hawaii
in europe
you know
plants
factories being
um
[Music]
established all over the the world
japanese money yes manhattan pebbles
beach golf course uh the um
yeah world trade what was it in in
manhattan the um
um one of the big buildings i mean is it
the land under rockefeller center
exactly
i remember um all sorts and so um
the intriguing thing was
where did all this money come from
because it was actually more money
than any economic theory
would uh would tell you should be coming
from japan and also they weren't really
earning much money on it so it was
against the economic incentives
and nobody could explain it and they had
you know these standard models of
capital flows didn't work and so i i
wanted to solve that puzzle and in the
at the peak in 1987
japanese long-term capital outflows were
i mean it was a world record amount
unprecedented
it was
twice as large as the already world
record current account surplus
um
where was the money coming from and so i
researched that and the answer to that
gave me an answer to many other things
including enabled me to to warn later in
1991 that japanese banks which at that
time were the biggest in the world and
the top 20 banks in the world were all
japanese
by assets you know um top 20 banks in
the world were all japanese this is 1990
1991 exactly this is right at the end of
reagan's two terms yes and at the end of
this uh you know japanese um economic
boom
and also japanese money flooding the
world and people were talking about the
japanese century now beginning uh which
didn't quite happen
but it took it took people a long time
to realize this but my so at that time
when
japanese banks were top and the economy
is growing at seven percent there was a
bit of a
you know glitch in the stock market
stock prices had fallen a bit 20
25
30
a bit more
but then the bank of japan in 91 was
lowering interest rates and most people
thought well that's the signal now buy
japanese stocks
that's when i put out my first paper my
conclusion was don't buy japanese stocks
japanese banks
are likely to go bankrupt and japan is
likely to move into the biggest
recession since the great depression
and you should
short japanese stocks which you also did
at the time and they knew it which is
why they were buying hard assets all
around the world like real estate
and the answer to the question where did
they get the money from
is actually they just created it out of
nothing
because i uncovered at the time
the the process that actually drives um
all of our economies
and and of course you know i found out
in japanese case
um you know economic growth is something
you get
only when there's also money creation
going on but money creation for
gdp you know your economy um gross
domestic product that's how we measure
the economy so money creation that is
used for investment and so on in the
economy
for transactions fueling gdp
if that increases you get more gdp more
nominal gdp
of course if money creation goes into
acid purchases you get an acid bubble
so i discovered this mechanism and what
is the money creation most people think
it's it's the government that creates
the money supply actually much later i
did a survey with with my students in
frankfurt we asked over a thousand
people
sort of you know in central frankfurt
probably above average educational
levels and the question was who do you
think
creates and allocates the majority of
the money supply
and then give them some options and of
course being in frankfurt includes the
bundesbank the german central bank
the ecb at that time as well also in
frankfurt
but the german government all sorts of
options
and most i mean 84 responded well it's
either the government or the central
bank you know yeah one of those ecb bond
you know on this bank
that's what 84 thought and of course
that's wrong because the reality is
governments don't create any money these
days that task has been
given away delegated that power has been
given away
um
by the people from the people to
somebody else um
central banks well they do create some
money
essentially the paper money the cash but
that's usually around only two to three
percent of the money supply so the
question is who creates the 97 of the
money supply that is fueling the economy
asset markets
um
you know if you do it correctly creating
economic growth
well
it comes from the banks
banks create money when a bank gives out
a loan
it's not using existing money it's not
using deposits
it is actually newly creating money out
of nothing so bank loan is always new
money creation new purchasing power is
given to the borrower and added to the
money supply
and this is new person about that didn't
exist before
now once you understand that then you
start to see how things fit together so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]